Harry talk to me about this song
sledgehammer I'm a big fan of
sledgehammer Peter Gabriel why do you
love that song so much I love it because
well I think it's like the best mixed
song ever
it just sounds incredible you mean the
record itself record itself yeah and
also we recorded a lot of the new album
at real world which is Peter Gabriel
studio in in England was that because
you loved the sound of his records I
mean it's an amazing studio you know I
wanted to get out of London but we all
got in there and we just wanted to blast
sledgehammer in the room so bad and we
were like do you mind if we do it and
the guys were looking they were like
everybody does it absolutely cranked it
let's do a little Fletcher okay because
you love this song yeah I'm excited to
hear this
[Music]
open up
[Music]
[Music]
new stuff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow Wow well done you reminded me how
great that song is it's great have you
guys ever performed that publicly before
now this is the first time